will you pray with me spirit of the
Living God bless this now are gathering
speaker and here straight from the heart
let it come by your aid and so may it go
to the heart amen in the year nineteen
fifty eight fourteen year old Bobby
Fischer won the US Chess Championship
Alaska was recognized as the 49th state
NASA was established and the first u.s.
satellite was launched into space The
Nutcracker was shown in full color on
primetime TV for the first time horizons
were ever expanding with a sense of
pride and potential and the future
seemed rosy and bright in the year
nineteen fifty eight following the Civil
Rights Act the year before there were
sit-ins at lunch counters in Oklahoma
and on buses and Alabama governors
closed schools in Arkansas and Virginia
and opposition to integration bethel
baptist church was bombed by the Ku Klux
Klan and Birmingham horizons were
shrinking left and right under Jim Crow
and the future was filled with
foreboding it was in the year nineteen
fifty eight that Charles Eric Lincoln an
African American scholar and a newly
ordained Methodist minister wrote this
prayer for love Lord let me love let
loving the symbol of grace that warms my
heart of grace that warms my heart and
let me find thy loving hand to still me
to steal me when I tremble at thy
command to love all humankind Lord let
me love the love may be the losing of
every earthly treasure i possess would
make thy love the pattern of my choosing
and let thy will dictate my happiness i
have no wish to wield the sword of power
i want no man to leap to leap at my [ __ ]
and nor let my critics feel constrained
to cower feel constrained to cower for
fear of summer appraisal at my hand Lord
teach me mercy let me be the winner of
every man's respect and simple love for
I have known dimer see though a sinner
whenever I have sought thy peace above
Lord let me love the lowly and the
humble forgetting not the mighty the
mighty and the strong and give me grace
to love those who may stumble to love
those who may stumble nor let me seek to
judge of right or wrong Lord let my
parish be the world unbounded let love
of race and clan be at an end let every
hateful doctrine be confounded that
interdict the love of friend for friend
five years later King would be sitting
in the Birmingham jail Medgar Evers dead
in Mississippi President Kennedy
assassinated less than six months later
and then just another five years Martin
Luther King as well would also be shot
and killed and yet another Civil Rights
Act would be signed as 150 US cities
erupted into riots and through it all
Charles Eric Lincoln prayed would make
that I love the pattern of my choosing
he and countless other African American
Christians prayed prayers for love as
they tried to embody their way into a
beloved community into God's kingdom and
sought to save us all in the process the
first time that I heard this prayer I
was an undergrad sitting in a pew at
duke chapel and listening to it it
occurred to me that this was a kind of
love that I could hardly fathom and I
wondered at that point whether I could
learn how to love like that when I saw
the lectionary had a sign first
Corinthians 13 here in early februari
just around the corner from Valentine's
Day the kind of cringed aside and even
at worship planning we discussed it and
then we decided that maybe singing this
contemporary version would let us hear
the words new experience them fresh you
know kind of for the first time because
we know those old words so well if I
speak in the tongues of mortals and of
angels but do not have love I think
people memorize that in Sunday school
some of you maybe if you grew up in a
church or love is patient love is kind
its scripted on greeting cards all over
the place right love bears all things
believes all things hopes all things
endures all things I think is cross
stitched into a pillow at my
grandmother's house this kind of
over-familiarity has a way of diluting
and numbing the sensation write the
words kind of stop meaning much of
anything at all but imagine hearing them
for the first time in the church in
Corinth being read aloud from the letter
from Paul when Paul would write these
letters the church would gather and then
one person would stand up and read it
out loud almost of Paul was there and
body kind of speaking the words to the
to the gathered group and call center
opens basically by denouncing them for
all of the jealousy and boasting that's
going on naming them as being puffed up
in favor for one for one against another
he writes at one point early on that I'm
writing not to make you ashamed but to
admonish you and then he very quickly
says I'm planning to come and visit you
and then he mentioned something about
should I bring with me a stick oh you
get multiple chapters in which Paul
discusses all of the particulars of
community living basically outlining
everything that they are doing wrong as
a
Church in detail one of my favorites is
when they gather to celebrate communion
paul says when you come together it's
not really to eat the Lord's Supper for
when the time comes to eat each of you
goes ahead with your own supper and one
goes hungry another becomes drunk what
do not have homes in which to eat what
or do you show contempt for the Church
of God and humiliate those who have
nothing what should I say to you should
I commend you heck no I don't come into
you it goes on and on chapters and
chapters until you get to this in
chapter 13 in which Paul is trying to
teach them how to love one another Paul
says you can have all the gifts in the
world but if you don't have love even me
look at me I mean Paul you know he's not
shy about naming his own gifts and so
he's listening all these gifts that
these people might have that you might
have one of these gifts of course he
himself with all of them and and then
the midst of it he's saying you know
even if I have this gift if I don't have
love I am nothing I gain nothing he
calls them to be imitators of himself
because Paul truly believes that he has
tried to make Christ's love the pattern
of his own choosing and he desperately
desperately wants the Corinthians to
choose that as well and to live into it
as he has tried to do in his own life
now I don't know about you but I can
imagine as the church in Corinth is
gathered listening to this letter
without loud that the reaction was may
be similar to the reaction of Jesus's
hometown crew gathered to hear the
scripture read out loud as jesus also
starts to become somewhat contentious
and to say the
you know no one should feel like they
are the privileged group that God works
with the people who are willing you know
we're coming off the lofty words of last
week where Jesus proclaimed good news to
the poor and release to the captives in
sight to the blind the year of the
Lord's favor all of it has been
fulfilled today it's wonderful and then
Jesus says ah the people are there in
awe until Jesus starts to get
confrontational and then suddenly
they're enraged and ready to throw him
off the cliff and I imagine that had
Paul actually been there reading his own
letter out loud maybe the Corinthians
would have been prepared to hurl him as
well I don't know but it turns out that
I guess God's good news is sometimes
very hard to hear that sometimes the
most loving words spoken in our midst is
a harsh one that shakes us out of our
habits and calls us to repentance into
new life in the Gospel reading Luke is
kind of foreshadowing in a way that
prepares us for Ash Wednesday it's
really it's well timed for us because
ash wednesday marks are lint in turn
with Christ towards the cross and so
this initial form of rejection just sort
of sets the stage for the kind of
rejection and the kind of violence that
would be executed later on and so as we
make this turn together and this journey
through Lent I hope that we can come to
know more deeply a love that bears all
things believes all things hopes all
things endures all things i hope that
worship can indeed be a place where we
experience and express the steadfast
love of god and reset our compass
so that we can walk together let it be
so I'm in